foreign
[Music]
oh my God what are you doing here you
know I'm just visiting my old haunts on
the off chance I might run into an X
from 10 years ago how many of you
running two so far
[Music]
if I still think about what would happen
if you hadn't left all those years ago
I've been kind of wondering the same
thing recently like if maybe I made the
wrong decision
[Applause]
you haven't felt that free in
I don't even know how long Sean honey
Mom hey I
Ellie Jojo
hey what a wonderful thing for us all to
be here so thank you to the bride and
groom for giving us a reason to
celebrate to Sean and Cassidy
thank you
I need to see this through whatever it
is you mean like with you in the groom
I mean we can just call him Sean
hi you're still here if my being here is
making you uncomfortable no no it
wouldn't be very cool of me to kick out
one of Sean's oldest friends
[Music]
[Applause]
oh she was cool she actually reminds me
a lot of me at that age
were he like a nudist I was I have an
idea
keep your eyes on the iPad Bradley Pitt
Campbell do not chase the naked ladies
Ally this has gone way too far I don't
know I don't know what to do anymore
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you